i don't know what the collective term
for a group of uh sky news presenters is
a sort of a launch of presenters
perhaps but hopefully uh
no introduction required now my far left
ed conway our data and economics editor
samantha washington
my fellow presenter trevor phillips my
fellow presenter and we're here really
to sort of chew over what we've picked
up over the course of the day but before
we do this skies
i don't know whether it still is our
slogan first with breaking news always
used to be didn't it but we do have some
breaking news which uh ed can uh
talk to us about which is that so we've
had the latest world economic outlook
from the imf in the last hour or so so
ed what are what are the highlights yeah
normally this time of year i would be in
washington but i have chosen rotherham
over washington dc
um and i think that was the right choice
definitely but so so the imf are having
their their annual meeting at the moment
and um they've just brought out their
world economic outlook so this is their
kind of their they do every six months
their opportunity to look at the state
of the global economy and that's what
what's interesting and it kind of feeds
into i think stuff on on all of our
sessions is
they've cut their global growth forecast
and they've done it partly in the face
of what we've been talking about you
know the supply chain uh crunch that
we're all facing they've raised their
inflation forecast and a lot of people
are looking at and saying you know is
that a kind of a bit of a stagflation
warning i mean i i don't know if i go
quite that far but but nonetheless lower
growth higher inflation um and
it goes back to this point that you know
that
we are in this kind of very difficult
moment at the moment
it to some extent you know there's a
good news story behind it which is that
you've got the global economy growing at
the fastest rate that we have ever seen
you know in the post-war era we we're
just not used to that the machine is not
just not used to six percent growth
which is kind of what we've got in in
the uk and the us and loads of other
places but as a result of that the whole
machine that underlies it is really
struggling to keep up and then you have
kind of this energy price shock and
you've got all of the other things
interacting so the imf's kind of put
their tuppence in and they they you know
they are officially concerned uh which i
imagine is a story that we're going to
be kind of talking about for the next
few days at least absolutely i mean one
of the big themes for me that's come out
of today and sam certainly when you were
talking to mark carney it came out in
spades which is the rising cost
of
the transition away from fossil fuels
that pivot towards net zero the cost is
becoming ever clearer and i wonder
whether the authorities are actually
being honest with publics about that
around the world well i think there's a
lot of debate about to what extent the
government needs to be subsidizing this
to what extent uh individuals are going
to be responsible but i thought one of
the really interesting things that came
out of talking to the former governor of
the bank of england
was the
the delta in the amount of investment
now going into uh on companies balance
sheets towards net zero goals so he was
talking about back in paris
less than a third of countries that were
there had net zero commitments and after
that that's gone up now to three
quarters
of countries but cascading down from
governments getting involved as has been
corporates also uh getting involved in
in green recovery and investing in green
infrastructure and he said that that
corresponding number had gone from five
trillion invested on companies balance
sheets up to 90 trillion of course
there's still a lot of challenges
because 90 trillion is an awful lot of
money but we need hundreds of trillions
to invest in in green infrastructure
some of the sectors are already
profitable i think solar and wind and
you can see what's happened with the
electric car industry as well you know
that you have the electric car companies
that are worth more than a lot of the
other
top car companies combined but it's
getting that money which is out there
isn't it ed i mean that's the size of
the global savings glut that we need to
somehow incentivize to get into these
green sectors some of which are not yet
profitable and it's about getting that
right combination of government support
uh corporate finance getting all those
incentives aligned to get the money
where it needs to be well it is i mean
the world is awash with liquidity but at
the same time with so many people
chasing these assets there's going to be
asset price inflation and you're already
seeing it in the elevated prices that
the likes of bp and shell are paying for
example to develop offshore wind farms i
think you know what's interesting
is that it feels real
you know
all of us have been to kind of
conferences you know perhaps like this
one or others where people have talked
very boldly about what they're going to
do about net zero or about kind of
greenifying their processes
but in the last kind of three or four
years it's just started to feel more
real hasn't it and that's kind of what
what mark carney was kind of talking
about that that has turned into real
money now it's turned into real
commitments but what's interesting like
you saying is
the
the fact that it's very easy to make
bold promises it's very easy to you know
be a cop and make a promise about about
something that you haven't necessarily
got a kind of strict plan for like sam
was was was quizzing mark connie about
but when that becomes real and you
actually have to implement it and it
leads to higher inflation it leads to
higher energy costs
then things can get crunchy and and i
feel like we're kind of getting to that
crunchy stage now you know solar solar
is much cheaper now why is it cheaper
it's cheaper partly because we've got
better at making solar panels but it's
cheaper partly because
most of these solar panels are made in
china
and what is powering that process coal
and coal is very cheap and now suddenly
china is deciding you know whether it's
actually going to start using coal
actually be using as much coal as it was
before and suddenly
solar might not look quite so cheap in
the future so you know this is this is
where
it gets interesting i say you know in
italics because i think
the next few decades are gonna be
more crunchy when it comes to uh to the
to the net zero debate and
and it's gonna affect all of our lives
in a way that i you know it hasn't
before and i imagine you know the public
and many of your businesses
are now actually thinking
this this this is something we need to
think very seriously about it's real
yeah can i add to that because i think
credibility is going to be so important
when to get the money flowing to where
it needs to be you have to accept that
government policy is credible that their
commitments are credible one of the
things i was pushing mark carney about
is is the uk government credible on its
own net zero commitments why are we even
considering investing in a coal mine in
gas and oil exploration in cambo sands
and he gave quite a politician's answer
to it didn't he but but i think
in essence what he was saying is at
least there's an inquiry they haven't
just gone ahead with it and when you do
the inquiry you have to look at the cost
and benefits of it which might not sound
very satisfactory because
you know there is another answer which
is just say no but actually if you do
the inquiry and you're exposing the fact
that there won't be any more need for
what comes out of this coal mine from
2035 then you start to think
you know the financial institutions
won't be investing in these things if
they think that it's going to be a
product that doesn't have lifespan
anymore you need cooking see the thing
is you need coke and coal for solar
panels that's you know again there's the
complexity that
i don't know if government has actually
fully comprehended that but you need
coking coal not just to make it a frog
understanding yeah i don't think the
frog has got that one either i mean i
think he's slightly further ahead than
some politicians dare i say but
it's not you know the green transition
involves
creating you know creating a lot of
carbon and that's that's the paradox
that i don't think has been fully
explained to
you know to the general public and and
maybe even to the politicians as well
and that's why
you know he gave a politician's answer
but i think until
that has you know
has been properly explained about what
the trade-offs are saying no to i mean
i don't think it's easy i genuinely
don't think it's easier the sort of
mechanisms you need in that transition
period are things like carbon offsetting
and then you get into the arguments well
you're just allowing people to pay their
way out of their emissions but you need
to get from a to b so there has to be a
way to it yeah i mean trevor you grill
politicians every every week
do you ever get the sense that
there could be more honesty from them
about the cost of the transition
well i think there could be more honesty
if i thought they knew what they were
doing
actually um
people can only be as honest as they
know
and i i
i do
think unfortunately that
in
politics exactly as ed was just saying
we haven't really started to have a
proper conversation
about what many of these things mean so
for example one thing that surprises me
is that politics isn't talking about
what
i don't know if it is but it could be an
esg
uh bubble i mean there is
that 90 trillion is going somewhere
but it's going more it's tracking um
it's marching
in uh pursuit of assets where things are
promised now the big example there is
fintech where you know people who
haven't made a profit and show no signs
of making a profit are being valued at
five billion dollars and but i think
that is also true
to some extent in terms of quote unquote
green assets that there's
chunks of money going uh in places where
there might be the promise but actually
nobody really knows
and the second thing is i think sam's
point very very important
it's going to be
harder before it gets easier
there's going to have to be
if any of these technologies is
successful there's going to be a load of
money chucked into it
before
anything comes out to the other end i
mean the one the example we have example
for us we've spent gigantic sums on
nuclear and actually we we sort of knew
what would happen with nuclear that
eventually it would pay off but even now
what uh
60 70 years on from
the size will be and all that
it's only just starting to wash its face
so i think there's a big problem
that politics basically
is not
equipped to deal with
because
when i talk to politicians
um
you know
there's no point me talking to them
about
what will it look like in 2050 because
most of the time they can't even
see what what it's going to look like at
2050 tonight
[Music]
they're thinking in five-year cycles
rather than 50-year ones
yeah
i mean one of the points that you tried
to tease out of mark carney was whether
the uk was set is setting the right
example as we approach cop 26.
yeah i mean the uk government's been
criticized by its own independent
climate change committee as i'm sure
many of you know
for not having really a detailed plan we
don't know you know what what the road
map is to get to net zero we don't know
what it's going to cost and we're also
hearing a lot about the tensions with
treasury about is is treasury going to
stump up
for this when we've got covert to pay
for and um
i i and all the rest of it so
just remind me of sorry i'm somebody was
talking to me in my ear and i lost track
of what i was saying
no i was just saying what did what did
you get make of his answer then when you
tried to tease that out of him
um tease it out of him about the he was
quite a politician wasn't it oh yeah
yeah yeah i mean
but he is he's a great politician what i
thought was interesting though is i
didn't get much out of him on that
because it was all very policy based and
you know you could give me one of his
rehearsed answers but when i was asking
him about
basically the style point which was you
know the way the prime minister frames
the language around this i mean he
references kermit the frog about it's
not easy being green and he's talking
about bunny huggers uh is that helpful
and he sort of smirked didn't any it was
more what he didn't say um um when i
asked him is that language that that you
would use and he said no
and he's obviously probably one of the
people in the world taking climate the
most seriously so i i think you can
deduce
what you may i think you got more of it
out of him you know i'm used to i i it's
someone i've both interviewed mark
carney before and we're both talking
about this backstage sometimes you know
sometimes he's quite tough to get stuff
out of but i felt actually what you saw
there was quite a good mark carney
interview where he did actually go a
little bit further than he usually does
um and you know i think both on you know
the the coal mine he talks slightly kind
of more freely about that than i
expected also about energy bills for for
households and businesses in in this
country and again it's it comes down to
the facts
that a lot of this stuff is no longer
academic i think that's this isn't it
this this is becoming real it's real for
for many of your kind of executive
decisions it's real for many households
as well
and it's you can't avoid it you can't
just talk in kind of generalities
anymore about this which makes it more
tangible for us as as a news
organization but also for
for the country
we haven't got an awful lot of time left
but before we do trevor if i can put
this politely you you probably you have
more miles on the clock than uh
the the rest of us
we've we've had this sort of he's
younger than you
certainly in uh spirit
um yeah it's it's a drugsy and it helps
i mean we've just gone through this
period where we've had cues at petrol
stations the talk is of inflation of
stagflation there's there's more than a
sort of whiff of the 1970s
about this as someone who's around in
the late 1970s i mean i mean i was there
too but i was only at school
do you think the comparison is going to
get into far many knots
[Laughter]
do you think these comparisons with the
late 70s are being overdone
uh i don't think they're being overdone
but i think they might be um
might mislead us um
in in summary i mean i i interviewed
michael hesseltone who was a minister
and that's 73 when we had three day week
and all that um
and i was saying to him that i was a
student at the time and they locked us
out of the laboratory because
you know we
we're just using
we didn't have the the power um
to to do the work that we're supposed to
do and if i had to go to the
library
i mean no student goes to a library in
daylight for god's sake i mean you'd
have to have a candle
happily i didn't go to the library ever
so it didn't matter but the point is
that
i think what we were seeing there was
the end of something
the disruption was we could see the end
of primary industries coal and so on
coming
um we didn't know what's coming next but
that was all about the end of something
and how we manage that process
today i think what we're talking about
is the beginning of something and we
just don't quite know how that's going
to work it struck me that the the fight
the panel that i was doing
is thinking about it uh simone rush
made it used a good example of a digital
company that's succeeding in lead and i
it struck me
what we're talking about now is a
destruction to some extent of geography
now the north used to be the north
because of coal
and salt uh and iron and ports
now
in a world where those things have gone
frankly those industries gone somewhere
else and what we're doing now is what
she was talking about in leeds
the geography is destroyed
one of the things i'm just wondering is
if we've
slightly killed ourselves the whole
today that there is going to be
something separate called the north and
whether what separates us is not going
to be
the primary you know economics and so on
but it just whether you
how you say the word
the word for the thing that you get into
when you really want to wash your whole
body i'm trying not to say it begins
with b
bath yes
or bath yeah that's a perfectly good
point and i mean the way that uh
digital infrastructure is being rolled
out you know working from home
phenomenon is very much a part of that
isn't it
but
that is basically all we've got time for
uh trevor
ed thank you very much um that concludes
today's event we've really enjoyed being
up here in this absolute astonishing
building somewhat chilly at times but uh
hope hasn't been too uncomfortable for
the uh with the heating on um thank you
for engaging in some fascinating
discussions and for being here and
sharing your thoughts with us in person
and online we are going to be back at
some point very soon with more big ideas
live but in the meantime thank you very
much indeed for company today